Parliament committees have heard and
questioned viraja Rover vice-president
designates in charge of values and
transparency and Joseph Burrell the
union's High Representative for Foreign
Affairs and security policy Vera der
over from Czechia is the nominee for the
values and transparency portfolio my
goal will be to make Europe more
democratic and transparent to make
Europe more resilient against new
threats including digital ones and to
make Europe more capable of defending
the values we cherish including the rule
of law and media freedom until now she
was Commissioner for justice consumers
and gender equality the lawyer and
businesswoman was heard by MEP s from
the constitutional affairs and civil
liberties committees they questioned her
position on the rule of law and tangible
consequences for countries that threaten
it Independence of judiciary issues
freedom of expression and freedom of
association
Joseph Burrell has been nominated as the
union's High Representative for Foreign
Affairs and security policy sitting as
vice presidents of the Commission and
chairing the Council of Ministers for
Foreign Affairs the Spanish Foreign
Affairs Minister is a former presidents
of the European Parliament speaking to
members of the Foreign Affairs Committee
Borel said that in an increasingly
turbulent world Europe needs to be more
assertive we should pull our national
sovereignties together to multiply the
power of individual member states and I
am convinced that we don't act together
Europe will become irrelevant mep x'
wanted to know how he'd encourage
european unity his position on threats
to the rule of law and human rights in
countries across the world and on
relations with key players such as china
or the US
the vote in parliament to decided the
commission as a whole is accepted or
rejected is scheduled for the 23rd of
October